on this wednesday night nato's landmark
decisions who's being allowed into the
alliance and the nation now named a
rival we need to take into account the
consequences of security plus canada's
new deal in latvia denials and a damning
letter the rcmp's top cop on the
political pressure she says she felt
guilty in the 2015 paris terror attacks
and the prison sentence in the historic
case and it may be june but the snow
must go on it's summer i'm wearing a
t-shirt and i get to be at the best hill
on this earth i swear the canadian ski
resort that is still a winter wonderland
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight eric sorensen
good evening and thanks for joining us
prime minister justin trudeau took part
in a nato leaders summit in spain today
that made history nato countries
including canada have agreed to admit
sweden and finland into the military
alliance it is the most significant
expansion of nato in a generation and a
major setback for russia's goal of
containing nato's power
russia ostensibly invaded ukraine to
keep nato from expanding on russia's
doorstep but the invasion has now
prompted sweden and most significantly
finland to join nato extending the
alliance along all of finland's border
with russia more than 300 kilometers it
not only establishes a much longer
military front directly facing russia
but bolsters nato's strategic advantage
by almost encircling the baltic sea
so nato is taking a new tougher stance
on russia and for the first time it's
identifying the potential security
threat from china our chief political
correspondent david aiken has tonight's
top story from madrid
prime minister justin trudeau and other
nato leaders made history approving a
new strategic concept a kind of master
plan for nato that for the first time in
the alliance's 73-year history
identifies china as a potential
strategic rival china is not an
adversary but of course we need to take
into account the consequences of
security when we see china investing
heavily in new modern
military capabilities long-range
missiles and nuclear weapons nato has
not updated its strategic concept since
2010 and that last one it did not even
mention russia as a threat that has now
changed russia's illegal invasion of
ukraine
we all know
is the biggest stress to our security
since world war ii
as he did two days ago at the g7 ukraine
president vladimir zelinsky joined nato
leaders by video conference for a
closed-door discussion on war strategy
and while nato forces will not engage
directly in combat on ukrainian soil
nato leaders vowed to stand by ukraine
for as long as it takes
u.s president joe biden said the u.s
would deploy more naval assets here in
spain new air defenses in italy and
germany and new army units in romania
and poland we're going to make up sure
that nato is ready to meet threats from
all directions this is the
biggest overhaul of our collective
defense since the end of the
cold war
as for canada it agreed to lead and
command an enlarged nato force in latvia
we are stepping up our contributions to
nato in a big way so we can keep
canadians safe and keep doing our part
on the world stage canada has been in
charge of a battle group of about 3 000
in latvia since 2016. that group
includes about 1400 canadian personnel
plus personnel from spain and other
european countries
now canada will lead a brigade that's 5
000 strong which means there will be
more canadian troops though how many
more has yet to be determined i would
like to use this opportunity to thank
anita to thank canadian government and
to send canadian people for empathy for
understanding uh about the situation
canada is also beefing up its diplomatic
presence in europe it announced a day it
would open full embassies with
ambassadors in estonia lithuania
slovakia and armenia eric
david aiken in madrid thanks david
ukraine's ministry of defense says 144
prisoners of war have been exchanged
with russia it comes as civilians were
again the target of a russian missile
strike this time an apartment building
in southeast ukraine ukraine says five
people were killed and at least four
more injured when a rocket hit the
five-story building in mikalive
northeast of there crews continued to
search through the rubble of the
shopping mall that was leveled by a
missile strike in cremenchuk at least 18
people were killed monday and 20 more
remain missing
ukrainian farmers are struggling to get
their grain to global markets later in
the newscast we'll explain what happens
if they don't and the impact on canadian
consumers
a memorial service delayed by the
pandemic was finally held in nova scotia
today for a veteran rcmp officer killed
during the mass shooting two years ago
that left 22 people dead among those
paying tribute was the force's top boss
commissioner brenda lucky who is facing
growing allegations that she and the
federal government played politics with
the investigation into the massacre
ross lord reports
[Music]
it was here in the community of coal
harbor nova scotia where constable heidi
stevenson lived and worked for many
years we knew heidi and we knew
i knew the family
and she gave her life for us so we
thought the least we could do was
show her respect
by coming to this
she was just doing her job as
you know and
this happened stevenson was killed while
trying to stop the porta pic gunman
after an exchange of bullets
it happened near the end of the killer's
13-hour massacre she was powerful
not because she wasn't scared
but because she went on
so strongly despite the fear
at this regimental memorial service
organized by the rcmp commissioner
brenda lucky praised stevenson as police
officers taking risk is part of the job
to stand strong when faced with danger
to be brave
heidi will be remembered for her courage
and strength of character
but lucky's own character is being
called into question by some of her
members
the latest allegations come from a
letter to commissioner lucky written by
nova scotia rcmp communications director
leah scanlon the mass casualty
commission investigating the massacre
posted the letter publicly on the
afternoon before the memorial service
the letter is scathing in it scanlon
tells lucky you informed us of the
pressures and conversation with minister
blair which we clearly understood was
related to the upcoming passing of the
gun legislation
scanlan recalls a feeling of disgust and
the commissioner lucky said by not
releasing details of the killer's
weapons nova scotia melodies let the
boys down referring to the surviving
sons of a neighboring couple murdered by
the gunman
in email statements lucky has repeatedly
denied interfering with her members
investigation and bill blair who led the
government's gun control agenda insists
he did nothing wrong dismissing
questions about whether he should stay
on in cabinet of course in contrast to
the rcmp's communication struggles the
memorial service was well delivered a
blend of poignant music
and heartfelt memories from heidi
stevenson's many friends we are all
incredibly lucky to have had heidi's
light shine in our lives
and i know we'll all carry her love in
our hearts forever thank you
ross lord global news halifax
police in b.c are piecing together the
motive behind tuesday's botched robbery
at a bank in saanich north of victoria
six officers were injured when gunfire
erupted three are still in hospital one
is in intensive care
two suspects were shot and killed at the
scene and the rcmp are now calling this
an attempted murder investigation
paul johnson is there tonight paul run
us through the chaos that unfolded
eric for those who watched the first few
seconds of footage here and mistakenly
thought you were watching something that
was happening in the united states you
weren't alone few would expect we would
see such spectacular violence happened
in a place like saanich b.c
[Music]
when the eyewitnesses tell you their
stories they describe agonizingly long
bursts of gunfire
some say it was continuous
others say it came in two volleys
whatever their vantage point it was
utterly terrifying
it was just like a machine gun going off
it was incredible and and all the
scattering and then the police came in
paul arnold was headed out to run
errands tuesday morning and instead
found himself taking cover with a young
woman who just missed walking into the
bank so i just grabbed her and we
fell to the ground and went underneath
the bush and huddled under the bush
until there was a first there was two
rounds of fire that no bystanders were
injured or killed in such a ferocious
daytime gun battle is nothing short of
miraculous
police killed the two suspects at the
scene and while it took a few hours to
rule out a third gunman on the loose in
the end the violence was contained to
the area around the bank of montreal
that was presumably the target of a
robbery
but police paid a heavy price six
officers were wounded too serious enough
to need surgery i can say
how moved i am
at the bravery demonstrated by these
officers they ran towards live an active
gunfire it's a bafflement that someone
would do an armed robbery of a bank on
the southern tip of an island
it's a big puzzle to us that this
happened still a lot of unknowns but one
intriguing question at this point is
what was the sequence of events that led
up to having members of the regional
swat team here to confront the gunmen
the fact that you had police officers
with the weapons and training
specifically for this kind of situation
very possibly saved lives
eric
paul johnson in saanich bc thank you
paul
in the u.s there's growing speculation
about new criminal charges in the attack
on the u.s capitol after tuesday's
stunning testimony the january 6th
committee heard about donald trump's
direct role in plans to interrupt the
confirmation of joe biden's election win
plans that trump pushed despite knowing
that the mob outside the capitol was
armed and dangerous jackson proskow
reports
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth her stunning testimony may
change the course of history i overheard
the president say something to the
effect of
you know i don't even care that they
have weapons
they're not here to hurt me as a former
insider in the trump white house cassidy
hutchinson has done what no one else has
drawing the clearest links yet between
the violent mob on january 6th and the
white house testifying the president
knew the crowd of his supporters was
armed and yet still demanded to lead
them to the capitol the president said
something to the effect of
i'm the effing president taking me up to
the capitol now after her bombshell
testimony the former president now faces
more legal peril than perhaps anyone who
has held the office before him he not
only knows about the violence but he is
fomenting it he wants to go to the
capitol and be the cheerleader of the
violence this put trump in the land of
seditious conspiracy
and inciting a riot that's if the
justice department chooses to act
members of two violent extremist groups
the proud boys and the oath keepers
already face seditious conspiracy
charges of their own
whether trump or his inner circle are
next is now a much more urgent question
as soon as you think you've heard
everything about what happened on
january 6
it turns out it was worse than we
thought
members of the secret service are
reportedly set to respond to some of
hutchinson's most damning allegations
politically there's now a sense trump
may emerge from the hearings too damaged
to mount a comeback in 2024. i've been
defending him but after yesterday when
she testified that he knew that there
were guns on property and that he still
encouraged people to go down to the
capitol that certainly changes my mind
the overwhelming response from
republicans has been stunned silence a
clue as to how damaging her words truly
were
jackson prosko global news washington
musician r kelly has been sentenced to
30 years in prison after being found
guilty of sex trafficking and
racketeering
the judge called the crimes calculated
and carefully planned one victim says
kelly is a pied piper who lured women
and children with his money and fame his
lawyers say they will launch an appeal
arguing the singer himself had a
traumatic childhood and deserves
leniency
the verdicts are in coming up the end of
the trial into the paris terror attacks
plus high honors who's getting the order
of canada
in one of the biggest trials in the
history of france the sole surviving
member of islamic state extremists who
terrorized paris with bombings and
shootings in 2015 has been found guilty
on all charges of terrorism salah
abdessalam was part of a group that
killed 130 people and injured almost 500
the latest tonight from crystal
gomencing
salah abdel salam is just the fifth
person in france to be sentenced to life
imprisonment with no possibility of
early release
on the night of november 13 2015 abdul
salam failed to blow himself up he
agreed to participate in a terror attack
but didn't detonate his belt he told the
court he changed his mind he couldn't do
it but he was still found guilty of
murder and being a part of a terrorist
enterprise
another nine members of a jihadi cell
including abdel salem's brother
did carry out coordinated strikes on
multiple locations in paris including
the bataclan concert hall
130 innocent people were killed
the verdict that has just been delivered
today is a verdict that is fair to
measure and above all courageous
the landmark case was heard in a
specially built courtroom involved some
300 lawyers and included testimony from
hundreds of witnesses
and assalam was just one of 20 men on
trial the others faced charges related
to assisting the killers the court found
all but one man guilty on all charges
six of the defendants were tried in
absentia believed to be dead
we all feel objectively tired mentally
tired physically tired 10 months is a
long duration victims and families are
still processing the verdicts and the
sentences but they could be seen as a
deterrent when it comes to acts of
terrorism crystal gomencing global news
london
still ahead the looming global food
crisis as russia's war in ukraine drags
on
before russia's invasion most of the
food produced by ukraine was exported
through its seven ports on the black sea
it was enough to feed hundreds of
millions around the world but in the
past four months the world's bread
basket has shut down causing upheaval in
global grain markets efforts are
underway to broker an agreement to
reopen some of those roots but as shaun
o'shea explains time is running out to
avoid a much larger crisis
this is the world's second largest
exporter of grain a little known fact
about a very large country how ukraine
plays a big part in feeding the world
absolutely absolutely something this
government agriculture official tells me
is plain to see from above
if you fly in a plane and watch ukraine
there is no land not sewn everything is
used he says most anyway despite the war
focused here in ukraine's east farmers
have planted about two-thirds of the
land they'd normally seed for the summer
but that reduction isn't a looming
problem main challenge for all of us how
to sell the grain which will be produced
and which is in growing now
the war here has altered how growers
move their grain to market general
capacity not enough it's real bottleneck
not enough railway
not enough storage facility ukraine's
black sea ports have been mined ships
can't get in to get the last crop out i
believe there's 25 million
tons
of grains there
and it can't be moved nobody has access
to that the worse is is is actually
ahead of us because of the conflict in
ukraine the war here in ukraine spells
trouble for world food supplies
according to experts and canadians will
feel the effects too
if access is not a problem
then food affordability is with prices
going up and canada is actually not
immune to this
we're seeing prices going up in canada
as well the middle east africa and
europe depend on ukraine's wheat and
other crops it's extremely difficult to
export grain from ukraine a reality
dictated by russia when it invaded
you're basically
weaponizing food
when you do that and that's exactly
what's going on triggering what sylvan
charlevois says will be a global food
security crisis in the weeks and months
ahead no matter how much ukrainian
farmers are able to produce this summer
shawn o'shea global news kharkiv
people in the alberta rocky mountains
are skiing in the middle of summer i'm
heather urex west near banff alberta
i'll have that story coming up on global
nationals
[Music]
governor general mary simon revealed the
newest appointees to the order of canada
among the 85 notable canadians golden
globe winning actor sandra oh former
sprinter and olympic gold medalist
donovan bailey and ethel blonden andrew
the first indigenous woman elected to
parliament and the first to serve as a
cabinet minister
all will formally receive the order's
insignia and a ceremony at a later date
well most canadians have swapped their
winter boots for flip-flops but not so
in the alberta rockies there's still so
much snow there that a mountain resort
has reopened for skiing as heather urex
west reports even as it warms up they
hope to keep the ski runs open until at
least canada day
they arrived in shorts and ski boots
tank tops and helmets ready to take part
in something surprising
a chance to hit the slopes in june and
july well it's summer i'm wearing a
t-shirt and i get to be at the best hill
on like on this earth i swear
sunshine village ended its winter
operations in late may but the spring
was so cool a lot of this year's snow
stuck around the suggestion came up in
june as we were approaching our summer
operations and we saw how much snow
there still was
it's only a few green runs and
conditions admittedly are not fantastic
i mean it's a bit sticky for sure
but you know
beggars can't be choosers when it's june
the unusual opportunity to ski and
snowboard in the summer time isn't
unprecedented here at sunshine village
but it has been a while the last time
the ski hill opened for skiing and
snowboarding on canada day was back in
1991. it seemed like there was a little
more snow in 1991
but uh
i wish they did this more often he's
always told me stories about like oh
1991 i skied canada day you gotta you
gotta get out there someday and so i've
been waiting for it so it's great that
they can uh ski there but that also
tells us a lot about
the snow conditions throughout the
canadian rockies
john pomeroy studies how climate change
is impacting canada's mountains and
while a snowy winter and a cool spring
is good news right now the wild
variability from year to year is all a
part of the changing climate a year ago
that we had the extreme heat
with temperatures up near 40 and even
above
this year though temperatures in the
mountains through canada day are
expected to remain relatively mild
giving snow bunnies one last unexpected
hurrah
heather urex west global news near banff
alberta
that's amazing and that's global
national for this wednesday night i'm
eric sorensen for tonight's york canada
we'll go from sunshine village to the
sunrise over innisfil ontario
we love seeing your canada please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching we'll see you back
here again tomorrow night
[Music]
you